the price of powering heavy industry is
rising and companies like wrightweld are
feeling the heat
steel fabricators they build the
skeletons of the modern economy the
frames of warehouses and shops but
spiraling energy costs are adding to the
price of their own power and huge
volatility to the market for raw
materials they rely on we could pick up
the phone to a supplier in the morning
and
by the afternoon we could have
experienced maybe a 20 pounds a ton
increase in in in cost at the end of the
day the the prices of
of our product is are going up um
we are now finding a little bit of
uncertainty clients are saying oh well
maybe i'll hold off to the new year to
do
do my building instead
businesses like this are paying the
price for soaring energy costs further
up the supply chain and it's left energy
intensive industries like steel like
paper chemicals and ceramics pleading
with government for help
in meetings with ministers industry
leaders have warned without financial
support the threat of shutdowns or even
closures is real
we'll be producing less steel uh then we
lose market share imports will then
increase when you lose market share it's
simple to lose it very difficult to get
it back then we're in this spiral of
losing market share not being able to
produce steel because you you're going
to lose money for every ton of steel you
make and then it becomes unsustainable
and that's when the permanent damage is
done
after a weekend of tension with the
treasury the department of business has
now formally requested taxpayer support
to help industries can i ask are you
right
there
not at all
one symptom of the energy crisis has
been resolved for now
cf industries paid by the government to
keep producing co2 for the last three
weeks says it's reached a deal with
suppliers to ensure production continues
until the new year though consumers are
likely to pick up the cost
it's the first day in the office so let
me go and have a look are we heading for
bleak winter i don't think so but let me
go and see what we can find it all came
as former tesco boss sir dave lewis
began working whitehall as the
government's new supply chain advisor
hired to help keep food on supermarket
shelves
the energy crisis is a global problem
keeping the british economy moving and
protecting consumers this winter
will be a battle fort on many fronts
paul kelso sky news